SAFETY WILL BE AGAIN MADAM
SECRETARY COULD CALL THE ROLL
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY. OUR
QUE HAN DEEP KAMLAGER-DOVE
QUIRK HERE SANTIAGO. WICKS. WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE ONE ITEM
ON THE AGENDA AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE SANTIAGO SENSES
INTERFERENCE WITH THE SENTENCE
SENSES CALPERS SENSES BILL OF
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES YOU
MAY BEGIN MISTER SANTIAGO I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING US TO PRESENT ON THIS
BILLING FOR YOUR HARD WORK OVER
THE LAST YEAR WE CALL THIS
ISN'T THE BILL OF RIGHTS AND
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS WE
COME UP TO THE US CENSUS COUNT
THAT PARTICULARLY IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT FELT LIKE
THEY CANNOT BE COUNTED SO WE
DECIDED TO CODIFY SOME BASIC
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO IT.
NUMBER ONE YOU CANNOT
IMPERSONATE A SEXIST OFFICER
NUMBER TWO YOU CAN OUT ACT LIKE
YOU'RE PURSUING A THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS IS CRITICAL
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THE SCANS
ARE HAPPEN OUR COMMUNITIES IN
IN MORE POORLY WE STAND LOSE
BILLIONS DOLLARS OR EVEN
POTENTIALLY COORDINATION WITH
ICE AND OTHER AGENCIES WHEN
FOLKS ARE BEING COUNTED THEN
HAS A COUPLE OF THE PROVISIONS
IN THERE WE WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR HARD WORK
HELPING US TO GET YOUR
SECRETARY IT'S OFFICE I WILL BE
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL. I WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
SO ABOUT THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
PROMOTING THAT SENDS A BILL OF
RIGHTS OF THE EVERYBODY GETS
KIND OF CALIFORNIA THIS DEFECT
A STATE OFFICE WILL ALSO
TRANSLATE INTO DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE IT'S IN THE ARE
PROTECTED AS ARE BEING COUNTED
IN NEXT YEAR CENSUS IN AND
FINALLY WILL UPDATE ONLINE SO
THE PROGRESS ON IN THE CENTERS
BILL OF RIGHTS SO WE WANT TO
TANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND CAN'T EMPHASIZE HOW
IMPORTANT THE BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE EVERY CALIFORNIANS
COUNTED. AND THEN ONE IS ABUSED
FINANCIALLY SCANNED OR
COORDINATE WITH AGENCIES THAT
WERE NOT ATTEMPTING TO DO SO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY ARMS
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT THANK. YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WHICH- IS IN SUPPORT. HI MY
NAME FIFTY EIGHT. HERE ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE OUT
EXPEDIA WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
TODAY. WE ARE HERE BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CENSUS AND- AS THE AUTHOR
EXPLAINED WE BELIEVE THAT IN
ADDITION TO. THE DETERRENT
FACTOR OF AN ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE NOT IMPERSONATIONS THAT
WE ALSO. MAKE CLEAR TO ALL
THIS. RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THE IMPORTANCE OF TAKING THE
CENSUS AND THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ASK FOR ASSISTANCE
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THEY CAN
VERIFY. A CENSUS WORKER. AND
THAT. WE ARE ENCOURAGING THEM
BY PROTECTING THEM TO TAKE THE
CENSUS. WE HAVE WORKED ON THE
LANGUAGE WAS STAFF SO WE WANT
TO. THANK ALL THOSE INVOLVED
AND ALSO WITH GROUPS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY ON SHORT NOTICE
COULD NOT. COME HERE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
MALL THAT. AND HELLO. SO WITH
THAT. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF THE TRAILER
LET'S REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
WE JUST FOUND A POSITIONAL
YESTERDAY AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ARE YOU
WELL. I HAVE A QUESTION IN YOUR
QUESTION FOR MR LACKEY. YES
GOOD MORNING I'D JUST OF NEED
SOME CLARIFICATION AS TO WHY
THIS DOESN'T ALREADY FALL UNDER
PENAL CODE SECTION FIVE TWENTY
NINE WHICH IS FALSE
IMPERSONATION. WELL WHAT IT SET
WHEN CALIFORNIA WE CAN QUALIFY
WHATEVER BECAUSE WE WANT TO GO
TO FIGHT IN THE IN THE SENSE
BILL OF RIGHTS SO LET ME ANSWER
DIFFERENTLY WE WANNA BE'S WE
WANT TO BE SQUEAKY CLEAN AND
CLEAR ABOUT THE FACT THAT YOU
CANNOT IMPERSONATE A CENSUS
WORKER. AND THAT YOU CANNOT ACT
AS IF YOU'RE IMPERSONATING A
CENSUS WORKER SO THERE ARE LAWS
ABOUT IMPERSONATING THEIR LAWS
ABOUT SCAMMING BUT WE WANT TO
BE. ABSOLUTELY CRYSTAL CLEAR
AND YOU AND I WILL PUBLIC BOTH
AGREE THAT IT'S A BI PARTISAN
EFFORT THAT WE ASSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUES TO
HAVE ALL ITS CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION NUMBER ONE WHEN IT
COMES TO COUNTING AND THE
NUMBER TWO ALL THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE STAND TO LOSE.
FIVE SO I THINK I THINK WE
WOULD AGREE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE AS IT RELATES
TO SECURING THE CALIFORNIA GETS
ITS FAIR SHARE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO IF THERE ARE ANY
MEASURES THAT WE CAN TAKE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY IS
COUNTED AND FEEL SAFE BEING
COUNTED. I'M SURE THAT YOU YOU
YOU'D AGREE THAT THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT. I JUST LIKE TO ADD.
AS THE ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION
THAT PENAL CODE FIVE TWENTY
NINE REQUIRE SOMETHING OF VALUE
IS MY UNDERSTANDING. THAT IS
TRANSMITTED SO THAT WHEN THEY
IMPERSONATE THEY OBTAIN
SOMETHING OF VALUE. IT IS HARD
TO CODIFY. THE DETERRENCE OF
JUST. FOR INSTANCE IF I WANTED
TO SOMEONE AND I SAID I'M FROM
THE CENSUS. I DON'T THINK YOU
SHOULD TAKE IT. YOU SHOULD YOU
SHOULD FILL OUT THE SURVEY OR I
PRETENDED TO BE FROM THE CENSUS
AND AYE DETER DO FROM TAKING
IT. QUALIFYING THAT AMOUNT IS
DIFF. DIFFICULT AS OPPOSED TO
TRADITIONAL FORMS OF FRIED
WHERE YOU WOULD SAY. I'D LIKE
YOUR CREDIT CARD NUMBER. AND
SAID THIS CLARIFIES THAT THIS
IS JUST TO SEEK OUT
INFORMATION. AND TO INTERFERE.
WITH THE PROCESS. OKAY THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY UP MISS COME
LOADED UP. THANK YOU I WAS
WANTING COULD YOU SHARE WHAT
WHY THE THOUGHT WAS TO MAKE IT
A MISDEMEANOR RATHER THAN AN
INFRACTION. I THINK THE IDEA
WAS THAT WE WANTED TO WEIGH THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CRIME. AND IT
IS CRITICAL I MEAN IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR. YES THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. I MEAN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WERE
TERRIFIED ABOUT GETTING COUNTED
AND WE THOUGHT THAT WE THOUGHT
THAT. I REALIZE THAT THAT WE
NEED FROWN UPON CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL. CRIMES FOR REASONS
FOR PEOPLE TO BE. PENALIZED IN
THE SYSTEM BUT THIS ONE'S
CRITICAL I MEAN WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT. WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT JUST PEOPLE
SCAMMING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE COMING TO PEOPLE'S DOORS
GRABBING PERSONAL INFORMATION
DOCUMENT AND DOT ARE NOT
DOCUMENTED AND POTENTIALLY A
COORDINATING WHAT WITH AGENCIES
A THE- WHAT'S THE TO SAY YOU
CAN POTENTIALLY CORNY WITH ICE
AND THIS IS CRITICAL HE CAN
SCAN PEOPLE IT'S HAPPENING IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD ALL THE TIME.
WE'RE ALREADY START TO SEE WHAT
PEOPLE KNOCK ON THE DOOR NOW
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THOSE WERE SCAMMING IT DIRECTLY
FOR SOME SORT OF MONETARY GAIN.
BUT WE ANTICIPATE THAT THERE
WILL BE THOSE WHO WILL BE STARS
CAM AS SCAMMING WILL START
COLLECTING INFORMATION FOR
OTHER OTHER PURPOSES IT MAY NOT
BE MONETARY PEOPLE ARE
TERRIFIED YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE GET COUNTER AREAS AND
WILL WE TELL ON THAT THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED FROM. FROM
BEING SICK FROM BEING SORRY I
KEEP MISSING OR SCANNED THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED WHEN THEY'RE
BEING COUNTED IN THAT THEIR
INFORMATION ISN'T GOING TO BE
USED FOR ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THE SENSES IF IT'S A CENSUS
WORKER WE NEED TO PUT SOME
TEETH TO IT DOES NOT ANY TEETH
IT'S. NOT GONNA. THAT IT'S NOT
GONNA HAVE THE IMPACT WE WANT.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE. IT IS
ALREADY. LOGGED IN BUT THEY'RE
NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT SOMEONE
ELSE THAT'S AFFILIATED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT MY GUIDE BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE A SQUEAKY CLEAN
THAT IT YOU CANNOT IMPERSONATE
OR ACT LIKE IMPERSONATING A
CENSUS WORKER. TO ADD ON THERE
ARE SPECIFIC CARVE OUTS FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF
IMPERSONATION AS YOU NOTED TO
SUCH AS LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
REPRESENTATIVES FOR INSTANCE
FROM THE NATIVE AMERICAN
BOROUGH BUT THERE ISN'T. A
COLLECTIVE IMPERSONATION OF A
GOVERNMENT WORKER. STATURE I'M
SORRY WE SHOULD BE TALKING TO
THE CHURCH I APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT NO IT WAS INTERESTING
CONVERSATION BUT WE SHOULD DOES
I APOLOGIZE. ANY MORE QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN COME LOADED OF.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER SANTIAGO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE MISTER
THANK YOU I AND HOPEFULLY. PART
OF THE COMFORT LEVEL THAT I HAD
ON A MISDEMEANOR AND IT IS NOT
OBVIOUS BUT ONE CHANGE ANYTHING
BUT I'M HOPING THAT BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT MOVING TO HAVING
JUDGES HAVING MORE DISCRETION.
AND I KNOW IT'S WRITTEN
MISDEMEANOR. FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLAR FINE OR BOTH HOPEFULLY
IT'S A THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. OR
A MISDEMEANOR OR BOTH IT'S A
DEAD ESCALATES NOT GO TO THE
AND WHICH I THINK IS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS AND I'M HOPING
THAT JUDGES NO. AS THEY LOOK AT
THE SEVERITY OF EACH CASE AND
HOPEFULLY OR NONE BUT AS A LOOK
AT THE SEVERITY OF EACH CASE
THEY KNOW TO ESCALATE IT AND
THAT MAYBE TO PREFERENCES IS
FINANCIAL FIRST BEFORE YOU
INCARCERATE AND THEN.
INCARCERATED AND TO DO BOTH. SO
GOD THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AN AYE
VOTE. CALDERON CLICK ON AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE MOTION FOR
SEVEN AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BAR QUE HAN MARCADO
AND I DEEP. KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE UP NOT VOTING
QUIRK. I SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO
AYE WICKS WICKS I. MEASURES UP
THANK YOU EXAGGERATIONS THANK
YOU WE NOW DURING THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING. FORTY
FIVE. OKAY